[Music]
sorry I just had a stupid ass thought
what if you went back in time to like
Roman era
you would be able to keep it in because
everyone's names would be you know
please come over here
and you're just like
yo you [__] with it testicle because
also if you say some [__] you'll just
get killed on the spot yeah yeah heretic
yeah yeah
rest of these come over here
did you say something
no no no no no no no no I didn't know
there's nothing it's just there's
nothing it's just
the rest of these I mean come on come on
what fatness come over here and explain
to me what is so funny about him
Let Me Lord
Milan it's me fatness fatness dick up in
your mouth
and then you're up there next to Jesus
yeah exactly
would you do to get up here is this some
guy on acid I'm the second coming yeah
for sure man
I [__] totally burned it fatness and
I got [__] now I'm clearly you know I'm
getting burned here I just love that
whole idea that Jesus was just like a
homeless guy who found [__]
like you know masculine or yeah
psychedelics in a bush
I just love the first one to eat
whatever plant yeah he's just the first
one on meth yeah I love that Vision like
that he's just the first guy on meth
it's tripping ball everyone's like yo
this is some crazy yes
[Laughter]
talking about like someone like God and
like he met him and yeah we must worship
this guy yeah this dude rules he rules I
bet you you know we know the 12
disciples as 12 dudes
bet you Jesus [__] it started with a
few baddies bet you
you know he's [__] just eases blue
collar iron worker you know making
swords and [__] yeah goes on a walk
finds a little just he was just making
his Burning Man float yeah that's that's
what they did yeah exactly and he
[__] had a little
you know well I didn't know the baddies
were the 12 disciples God damn
you're getting topped off over there
holy [__]
come over here
tell me this I'm just picturing like
kind of you know like kind of Timothy's
chalamet Vibe you know but Arab
he's the first guy to discover drugs
yeah bet you he just turned up a little
bit with a couple girls yeah yeah
probably he's like you know he's in the
blacksmith shop two ladies catch him
like you know walking out they're like
oh my God you work here yeah yeah
re-headed right now I was just gonna go
to the temple or some [__] I don't know
yeah you have a great body I'm I'm both
of these and this is uh
and this is Booth
I don't know I don't know yo listen I
found this [__] this plant
I was gonna break some [__] down if you
want to hang
bet you they just got you know nothing
happened it just got a little high they
were like he's funny yeah
and then just a couple dudes took note
and they were like yo top G how do you
know
Jesus yo top Jesus
top Jesus how do you get it like that
and he's like hey you just gotta be
chill
yeah then he did a little too much yeah
you know then he was like posting Clips
yeah yeah on the second coming
out but those those clips man he's
putting out Scrolls yeah exactly and
these dudes are like yo this is our boy
and then uh the rest is history that's
the story of Jesus the King was like
who's this [__] homeless loser taking
all the baddies from me
that's good yeah thanks dude
no that was pretty [__] dumb but it's
all right I laughed thanks
oh
we just did a tandemic
[Laughter]
the white part of your brain is just
attacking I know it's like every time
you want to pronounce it you're like
juice
I can't say it right I'm trying it just
won't let me
the drum jembe
oh there we go